vous promet encore un bel avenir et vous
verrez arriver à la télévision dans les
temps qui viennent dans les années nous
allons vivre des tas de nouveautés ainsi
par exemple l'ajout vous connaîtrez la
publicité la publicité vous savez existe
à la télévision américaine déjà et
astucieusement les agents publicité
essaye de m comme on dit la publicité en
situation c'est ainsi que quand la dame
aux camélias tous ont fait de la
publicité pour des pâtes pectoral
alors pour les agents publicité qui
auront à faire de la publicité dans
quelques années nous proposons quelques
exemples pris dans la littérature
française
lamartine ainsi toujours poussé vers de
nouveaux rivages dans la nuite éternel
emporté sans retour ne pourrons nous
jamais sur l'océan des arbres jetés
langues
un seul jour mais si je des landes il
est si simple d'avoir un beau stylo à
bille leconte de lisle midi wade été
épandus sur la plaine tombant nappe
d'argent des auteurs du ciel bleu ne
laissez pas tomber midi appelé l'horloge
parlante dès 11h55 corner robe unique
objet de mon ressentiment roma qui vient
tombera d'immoler moon amant romeu qui
t'a vu naître que ton coeur adore roman
enfin que je hais
comme il a raison au passé vos vacances
à venise vers l'est qu'as-tu fais toi
que voilà pleurons sans cesse dit
qu'as-tu fais toi que voilà de ta
jeunesse ma jeunesse mais j'allais
passer au lycée condorcet le lycée du
succès victory prononçant suffisent à
fait pareil aux dames a pas
de victor hugo pour les parents les
dents